former secretary of state hillary
clinton is weighing in on the potential
decision of the supreme court to
overturn roe v wade in fact she told cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell it's about abortion
rights yes but also more than abortion
rights
this opinion is dark
it is incredibly dangerous and it is not
just about a woman's right to choose it
is about much more than that and i hope
people now are fully aware of what we're
up against because the only answer is at
the ballot box to elect people who will
stand up for every american's rights and
any americans says look i'm not a woman
this doesn't affect me i'm not black
that doesn't affect me i'm not gay that
doesn't affect me once you allow this
kind of extreme power to take hold
you have no idea who they will come for
next
janet chamleon joins us now from texas
with a look at another major issue in
this debate abortions using pills janet
good morning
eureka good morning to you right now the
laws on a medication abortion really are
a patchwork from state to state but if
abortion is no longer constitutionally
protected a lot of women could lose
access to it
a medication abortion is two medications
used together to terminate a pregnancy
generally within the first 10 weeks the
pills are taken over two or three days
it's the most popular option in 2020
making up more than half of all u.s
abortions what are you seeing in terms
of demand for medication abortions
seeing a huge increase in demands
christie pitney is a telehealth abortion
provider licensed to prescribe the pills
in five states and the district of
columbia
our rights are not medication abortion
is seen as the next battleground in the
abortion battle
19 states have already banned telehealth
abortions requiring a clinician be
present when the woman takes the
medication including south dakota right
now two appointments are required for a
medication abortion one for the initial
consultation and one to receive the
medication
some lawmakers want to mandate three
appointments the consultation and one
for each of the medications
this woman is the clinic director
because it is already a very
huge lift to have these women come back
for two appointments
come back after their
informed consent then asking them to
come back to finish taking the
medication that they have been taking at
home safely for years and there's no
medical reason
in other cases women are using overseas
providers like the aid access in austria
which sends the medication from
pharmacies in india
pitney works with that group and says
interest has soared monday was one
thousand two hundred and ninety visitors
tuesday was thirty eight thousand
hundred 530 visitors so it's really
significant
eight access says many of the inquiries
that it's been fielding over the last
few days have been women
wanting to get the pill prescribed now
not because they need it now but just in
case they do in the future eureka
janet thank you for your reporting